I'm Alexandra.
I'm a software engineer at Bella, we're making
a product that acts as copilot for a manager,
one on ones and feedback.
If that's useful, check out bella.app.
And what I was to talk about today is something
completely different in my spare time.
It's transferring all the data you need other
SMS.
Why would I build something like this when
we have data on Wi Fi connections all over
the world?
I come from a country where a data plan for
2 gigabytes a month costs 55 Euros and only
works in my hometown.
Three quarters of a million people are using
dialup Internet in their homes.
I come from Canada.
So, the Internet is so, so expensive just
when I'm at home, that when I'm traveling
somewhere, to come to Berlin, the prices are
out my price range.
I like to travel, this data is an issue.
When I travel, I love to visit Paris and the
streets look like this.
I get lost really easily in a grid like structure.
When I'm over here, I need data to get around.
And I could technically download a map offline
and use that.
But that doesn't give me transit directions
which is something I really need when I walk
an hour in the wrong direction.
I need a subway to get back home.
When I was trying to come up with a solution
for this problem, I noticed like I can't afford
the data plans.
But SMS without a data plan costs about 15
cents per message.
I tried to work around that.
When I was starting a solution to this problem,
chatbots were the big thing at the time.
I set up this problem, setting up a Python
server with SMS and grabbing it from the Internet
and grabbing the directions and text it back
to me.
I could do something simple, how do I get
from point A to B and get the Google Map directions
back in one SMS.
I could do this for 30 cents per direction.
Which is pretty good compared to what I would
be paying for data otherwise.
And this really worked, and I used it lot
when I was traveling.
But the issue is when you get a little bit
of access to the Internet, you start to crave
it quite a bit more.
So, I was building these one off integrations
to figure out ratings for a restaurant I wanted
to see or a translated word I didn't know
and do all this stuff.
And building out all these integrations as
a one off took up a lot of time.
I thought, there must be a better way.
I'll just build a browser.
And that's what I'm gonna show you today.
So, your two main components to the project
I did.
There's the Android app on one side and the
server in NodeJS on the other.
The app I made in Android because I was it
just for me.
I don't have an iPhone.
I didn't care about iOS.
And I'm using Java instead of Kotlin because
there was a lot more on StackOverflow on SMS.
That was a good solution for me, I'm not an
app developer.
And NodeJS, I thought it would be fun you
to use JavaScript on a browser where it doesn't
belong to make this JavaScript less browser.
And then Twilio for the communication.
And Twilio does a lot of things, I bought
a phone number from it and it let me set up
an end point to forward all any SMS to.
I can send a text message to my Twilio phone
number and it will forward all those messages
to my server.
So, before I jump into the project, just to
set up like a limitation I had to deal with,
SMS can only handle 160 characters at a time.
If I want to create a browser, I'm going to
have to transmit this data less than one Tweet
at a time.
So, for more context on the issue.
Like this Google web page looks very, very
small.
It's just a text box and the logo and a button.
But the thing is, if you actually look at
the page source, not including any CSS, not
including the images or any sources being
loaded in, this web page is a quarter of a
million characters long.
If you were to transmit this entire thing,
1300 SMS, not including the ones dropped along
the way.
In Twilio fees alone, I would have been paying
$10 to transmit this Google page.
It defeats the purpose of being a cheap solution.
So, we have to do a lot on this page to get
it to work.
But if we were to imagine what this Google
page look would like building it up from scratch,
we wouldn't imagine all the CSS to make it
load.
We would imagine this little bit of HTML that
sets up the form and the text box which is
with a we need and takes one SMS.
This is how we envision a lot of the web pages
to make this project work.
So, we're going to walk through the life cycle
of a request and that's starting on the Android
side in the app.
Right off the bat we get into this huge limitation
with systems because the URL spec says that
a URL can be 2,000 characters longitudinal.
So, that could take up 13 SMS which is a lot
more than we want to deal with.
The first thing on the app side, and the app
looks like this, a text box and a go button.
Very simple browser.
We're going to start off by chopping off everything
that we don't really need.
So, the browser is going to be a very text
based browser.
We're not going to allow any kind of cool
single page applications.
We can chop off anything that has a pound
symbol, page, whatever.
We don't want any tracking IDs or query parameters.
Everything in black after the URL there we
can get rid of.
And same with the HTTPS, www, at the start
of the URL because it's assumed that all websites
have that anyway.
So, the part in yellow is what we're going
to be sending over as an SMS.
And that's gonna look something like this.
I'm not going to cover the Android side of
things too much.
But make sure we have send, receive and write
permissions on Android and use their simple
SMS manager API which lets you just specify
the destination phone number which in this
case is our Twilio one.
Specify the text that you want to send and
then it just gets sent off.
So, then Twilio picks up on message and converts
it into a format that the server will read.
It comes with a bunch of metadata.
We're only going to care about the body, who
it's to and from so we know who to send this
message back to.
So, this message gets sent over to the server.
Which we're gonna look at next.
So, a lot of us probably working in React
or some kind of like componentizing library
or framework all day.
So, we kind of forget how big our HTML ends
up really being because we're only dealing
with these little tiny components at once.
If like me and page source accidently instead
of inspect element all the time you end up
with a massive wall of text.
And how on Earth are web pages this big?
This is what the Google source page looks
like.
This is what we're going to have to deal with
and parse before sending it back over for
a text.
But there are a lot of things that we can
remove from this off the bat.
We don't care about comments, we don't care
about header data.
We don't care about CSS or any that have stuff.
So, there's a lot of stuff we can take off
pretty easily to get this to work.
On the server side, what we're gonna do is
start by grabbing the URL that Twilio sent
us, making a request to that URL by pre penning
the HTTPS to it and then use a library called
Cheerios which is jQuery for the server side
pretty much.
And use that to get the body off of the HTML
because jQuery makes that quite easy.
And then once we have this body, we're going
to start to remove a bunch of the HTML.
For that, I used a library, sanitize HTML.
So, line four that I highlighted lets you
specify specific tags in the HTML that you
want to allow.
So, here we're only going to allow anchor
tags, inputs and forms.
Those are the only elements in my opinion
that really provide any kind of value to the
user in a text based browser.
Lines 7 10 highlighted shows the specific
attributes on those tags that we are gonna
allow.
So, we're not gonna allow class name because
we don't have CSS anyway.
We're not gonna allow image tags because we
can't really load images over SMS.
And we're going to start loading these things.
The last bit that's highlighted in the exclusive
filter.
So, sanitize HTML lets us specify a function
of the tags and attributes to decide whether
we want to show certain things.
So, one of the examples I have there is we're
going to get rid of all of the hidden inputs
because the user can't see those anyways so
it's not going to provide any value.
And we're gonna get rid of policy URLs and
terms and conditions.
No one is going to click on those anyway so
it's kind of wasted space.
Now we have essentially a whole bunch of text
and a couple of tags left in the HTML.
We're going to start to compress this text.
And we could use something like Gzip.
But that's not fun.
So, we're gonna forget about any kind of real
compression.
So, in the English language there are a lot
of words that we use super often like the
and.
And a lot of single letters that are words,
I and A. And any common English word can be
mapped to a single later that's not a word,
everything that's the becomes T, and becomes
ampersand or whatever letter.
And on Android side, doing the decompression,
we know if that letter is there on its own,
it means the because it's not a word otherwise.
And to do that, it's very, very simple.
We have to set up a dictionary mapping these
words to their shorter versions and then go
through the text and do a replace all.
Another way of compressing the text is through
the source APIs.
So, if we're visiting a website like Wikipedia,
there are going to be a lot of big words that
don't need to be that big.
So, what we can do is find those very large
words, use a thesaurus API and see if there's
a matching synonym that's much shorter.
Pen ten chair is many letters and jail is
a four letter word, we don't care about the
word, do a replacement.
This is a 66% compression which is quite a
good compression rate.
The last way we're going to compress the text
in our HTML is by replacing links.
So, when you're using a website on your phone,
you don't care what a link actually is.
You just care that it takes you to where it's
supposed to take you.
The links can be really, really long.
Like up to 2,000 characters.
So, instead of sending over these links that
no one is actually going to be reading, we're
gonna replace them with really short, random
strings.
So, when a user clicks on a link on the app
side, that short link is what's gonna be sent
back to the server.
The server's gonna know that short link means
that long link and it's gonna fetch the correct
data to send back to us.
And that's gonna look like this.
I'm using Reddit to store the pairings of
short to long URLs because we don't need anything
super persistent.
Most links are not going to be clicked on
anyway and the web page is probably going
to be gone in five minutes.
What we're doing here is there's a function
that takes the phone number from the user
and the actual URL that is in the web page
and it's going to store it in Redis where
the key is the phone number and the short
URL so it's really easy to retrieve when it's
sent back.
And then the value of that is the full URL.
Now, the last bit of compression we're going
to do is on the HTML itself.
So, we've compressed all the English text,
we've compressed the tags and attributes.
But we still have going to have a lot of large
tags like this.
And things like input or type and name and
value and all those tags that we do allow
are going to show up pretty often.
So, we can remove those and replace them.
A nice thing about the SMS characters is that
it supports all of the English or all of the
English or letters and numbers and things
that you see on an English keyboard plus the
whole Greek alphabet.
So, what we've done here since all the individual
letters are already used by our English compression,
the text compression, we're going to start
mapping specific HTML tags and combinations
of symbols to these Greek letters.
I tried to map it by color here, the open
bracket input matches the first character,
type equals open quotation mark is the second
character.
So on.
This brings it down from 44 characters to
12 characters which is going to provide a
significant compression.
So, now the HTML is ready to be sent out.
But an annoying thing about SMS is that there's
no guarantee of delivery and there's no guarantee
that it's gonna be delivered in the right
order either.
So, you might end up with a situation where
we've sent out six SMS, but only four of them
get there and they're all out of order.
We're not going to really care about the part
where the SMS are dropped in this project
because it's just a small project for me to
access the Internet for fun.
And if we did worry about that, we would have
to build out an entire pact delivery network
where you have to figure out which messages
were dropped, how to recover from that and
that's just a little bit more effort.
But we are going to worry about this out of
order problem.
And to solve that, the HTML that we have is
going to be divided up into the 160 character
limit.
And we're going to pre pen some metadata to
the start of each message that shows the total
number of messages in this web page and then
the index where that SMS falls so that when
we put the HTML back together it's in the
correct order.
And to send out those messages, we're just
going use Twilio's library.
Very simple, Twilio, send message.
And it goes off and that's all I have to do.
Now the messages are sent and we're ready
to start getting them again on the Android
side.
So, Android has a thing called a broadcast
receiver which is something that listens out
for certain signals that are sent within your
phone.
So, here we have set up a broadcast receiver
that listens out for messages coming in specifically
from the number that we own on Twilio.
So, what this is doing is it's just listening
for that message to come in.
And then it's grabbing the text from that
message and sending it other to an activity
which is Android's way of saying a new you.
And in that new view, the first thing we're
going to have to do is reverse that Greek
letter conversion that we did to get the proper
HTML back.
We're going to reverse the shortened English
words.
We're going to add some spaces between closing
and opening tags so there's a little bit of
format in our page.
There's no CSS to make it look good.
We're going to try to break it up a little
bit.
And then we're going to load the HTML.
So, Android has my favorite feature ever which
is called a web view.
And web view is something that lets you have
a like a little version of Chrome within your
app.
And this was the most exciting feature for
me because going into this project I didn't
know that you could pass a web view in actual
HTML string, I thought you could only pass
a URL to load.
I thought I would have to build my own browser
and rendering engine and that didn't sound
like tons of fun.
This takes care of everything.
Chrome is just going render everything properly
for us.
And this is what it ends up looking like.
So, if we load if we load Google .ca, on the
left we have what this looks like in the app
which is basically what Google looked like
15 years ago.
On the right side is the SMS that you can
actually see coming in your default messaging
app on your phone.
So, this entire web page took just three SMS
to transmit instead of the 1300 otherwise.
And the code is not specific to Google.
It's applicable to any text based website.
So, we could just hard code this website instead
like on one of the first few slides where
it's just one SMS to transmit and that would
have taken even less data to send over.
So, I have dial up in the name of the talk.
And I was curious, how does this actually
compare to dial up Internet?
On my phone, loading Google takes about 2
seconds using like regular data or Wi Fi.
On dial up a couple years ago, it would have
taken a minute to do.
And on my phone, it's about 10 seconds when
my phone is working.
If you're somewhere where you don't have any
other axe out Internet, me travelling to Europe,
10 seconds is not that bad to wait for a website
to load.
So, SMS is not secure at all.
It is subject to be intercepted.
It is not secure.
One of the ways I prevented people from misusing
this is by removing in I kind of sign in links
from the HTML and doing that.
But otherwise, this is not something that
should be used to log into anything.
On the bright side, though, because this is
a custom browser, there's no tracking.
So, it's technically more private than your
general browser.
Something that would have made this project
quite a bit easier is using MMS instead of
SMS.
I could have transmitted the entire website
just by compressing a little bit and sending
it over very, very little for not that much
more expensive.
But that's not fun.
So, didn't do it that way.
There are a lot of things I want to do with
this project.
So, phones are, by nature, bidirectional in
communication.
So, we could do something really easily with
web sockets because a server can just ping
the phone whenever it wants.
We could do AJAX.
For websites we visit a lot like Twitter or
something, the format of every Tweet is exactly
the same.
We could store the HTML in CSS to re create
the proper Twitter on our phone and just use
the SMS to get the actual text content.
We could support JavaScript.
Might be a little difficult because we're
removing so much HTML.
But it would be a fun problem to figure out
how to map JavaScript to the HTML and properly
compress those and my favorite, what I'm working
on now, is true dial up for this project.
We're not doing dial up because it's SMS.
But we could do a phone call to transmit data
like dial up used to work.
That would be quite a bit cheaper.
It would be much faster, and it would be real
dial up in that case because you could use
your phone while the website was loading.
So, there are probably a lot of you thinking
this is ridiculous, there are cards for this
purpose.
I didn't know about this until a couple months
ago.
[ Laughter ]
So, if you're traveling to Europe, you can
get a SIM card like for 20 gigs for very,
very cheap.
And 20 gigs compared to my 2 gigs at home
is essentially unlimited data.
This is what I get when I travel now.
And it's a much better solution.
But when I'm in Europe, I usually come for
the two weeks you're allows with a SIM card
plus a day.
My project comes in handy for that one extra
day.
And so, my talk or my the code is available
on my GitHub.
There's a link to that from my website.
And, yeah.
That's my talk.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]